hello there it's PS Plus update time
once again the mid-month update for
extra and premium tiers of PlayStation
Plus and this month is spectacular you
can grab the following games from
February the 21st that's this coming
Tuesday the headliner of the month is
Horizon forbidden West released one year
ago this week we once again fill the
boots of Eloy a child Outcast who grew
up in a post-apocalyptic world where
machine animals and dinosaurs roam the
land freely a new threat is coming and
once again A-line must unite all the
tribes in the region to face it together
the combat in Horizon is primarily
focused on your bow changing arrows to
suit the situation there's something
really special about systematically
dismantling a robot dinosaur one
component at a time forbidden West also
has improved melee combat with a cool
surge system that feels kind of like a
limit break in Final Fantasy and
exploring has been upgraded too with a
grapple hook for verticality and a
glider too because nobody wants to climb
down a mountain we want to jump off on
PS5 Horizon forbidden West on Metacritic
is an 88 out of 100 and look it just so
happens that the new DLC is coming soon
next we have Borderlands 3 both on PS4
and PS5 the bombastic looter shooter
with the iconic cell shaded art style we
play as a vault Hunter and can go it
alone or with up to three other
real-life players to open those vaults
and collect the treasures inside of
course like always there's bad guys who
want to stop us this time it's the
Calypso Twins and their use of social
media to recruit followers Borderlands
is known for its weapons and Borderlands
3 has the most we've ever seen randomly
generated firearms that can be
absolutely insane like a gun with legs
or a weapon that becomes a throwable
grenade at the end of the magazine The
Vault Hunters we choose from have unique
abilities in battle and are fully voiced
with unique dialogue making it easy to
replay the entire game again with a
different Vault Hunter bodlands 3 on the
PS5 currently sits at a 91 on Metacritic
making this an unmissable game
[Applause]
and the bangers keep coming the Quarry
joins PS plus extra an interactive drama
in which a bunch of summer camp
counselors are being hunted down Friday
the 13th style we decide each of the
councilors actions and reactions and
ultimately decide who survives the night
packed with jump scares and impossible
decisions I challenge you to get
everyone alive to the end credits who am
I kidding unalive them all supposedly
there's a total of 186 possible endings
so replay value is assured Metacritic 74
out of 100 but wait there's more horror
next we have the scariest Resident Evil
ever made re7 biohazard first released
in 2017 re7 took the usual third person
game perspective and threw us into first
person viewer heightening The Fear
Factor we play as Ethan Winters as he
receives a message from his wife who's
been missing for three years leading him
to a Shack in the middle of nowhere then
this becomes a living nightmare for
Ethan as he tries to survive against all
the odds including a family that's
weirder than mine if you can't handle
jump scares and the constant feeling
that someone is watching you maybe avoid
this but for those who love horror re7
is amazing especially the first three
hours oh and it can be played on good
old psvr if you're hardcore average
reviewer score is an 8.5 out of 10.
Tekken 7 is here to end the story of
hayachi Mishima and his constant warring
with his son and Grandson in this iconic
one-on-one Fighter the series has
evolved to include rage abilities to
completely change the flow of battle in
a second with a cool little cinematic
cut scene it just feels more epic than
ever before the online only Co-op third
person shooter outriders is also here
which takes typical cover shooter
mechanics and layers Elemental
superpowers on top there are four
different class types to choose from
each focused around a different play
style the trickster is all about speed
and manipulating time to slow others
down the Pyro Mansa likes fire a little
too much the Devastator is more tanky
and can use the Earth under their feet
as a shield and the technomancer has a
turret to assist if that isn't your
thing check out Scarlet Nexus for a
blend of action from Devil May Cry and
the jrpg storytelling of something like
Persona the combat is over the top it's
flashy as heck it's superhuman with a
focus on timing as the difficulty slowly
ramps up the storytelling on the other
hand is seen through two campaigns one
for each of the two main characters both
Heroes join two separate platoons to
fight against these otherworldly enemies
and although their paths cross to fully
understand the narrative two
playthroughs are needed a cool mechanic
in game is all about your squad in
between missions you'll Venture back
home and you'll have some down time this
is your opportunity to talk to other
members of the group and build up bonds
leading to New Missions or improved
abilities Scarlet Nexus on Metacritic is
80 out of 100. for those who want to
take to the skies check out Ace Combat
7. it's a strange mix of simulation and
arcade Styles which is pretty impressive
it's mainly for people who know the
difference between an f41 Phantom and an
A10 Thunderbolt is Ace Combat 7 for you
Earth Defense Force 5 asks players to
join the military and fight off an
invasion from enormous insects with solo
couch Co-op and online play across
hundreds of missions and then we have a
bunch of RPGs in the shape of onenaki
Lost sphere and I am setsuna and to
round off the month it's the Forgotten
City an open world exploration game set
in ancient Rome although there's tons of
combat here it's not the main focus we
are actually asked to solve a mystery
using your wits as much as your fists
and now over to the premium tier which I
believe is called Deluxe in some
countries this month a modern remake of
a classic is here Destroy All Humans but
it's the PS4 version of the PS2 game we
invade Earth and take over by force or
cunning and the occasional anal probe
The Legend of Dragoon on PS1 joins PS
Plus premium for the old school Gamers
alongside Wild Arms 2 and Harvest Moon
Back to Nature and that is our month PS
plus extra really brought it this month
in my opinion what do you think I'm Adam
you're awesome it's been a pleasure see
ya